here on campaign check with scrutinizing
claims made by political parties on the
campaign trail and today let's look at
an important recent story the floods in
the north of England and Labour's leader
Jeremy Corbyn now here's claims the
Conservative government's spending on
flood defences until 2021 heavily favors
London and the southeast but does it
first let's look at the big picture and
you can see six billion pounds has been
planned for flood protection schemes in
England over the coming years of which
4.4 billion pounds comes from central
government plus 1.6 billion from local
bodies and others so let's drill into
that 4.4 billion and where it's spent
you can see this map it shows you levels
of planned spending per constituency
across England and the dark of the area
the more is being spent there and as you
might expect a lot is being spent in
coastal areas but it's Greenwich and
bullish home to the thames barrier which
gets the most they can see there are
some northern constituencies getting
large amounts as well but that's a
Labour's claim is most of the money
being spent on london the south-east
this chart breaks that down planned
spending on flood defences per head by
region and yes as Labour says look it's
the southeast and then London getting
most of the funding while the North East
and West Midlands get the least but
here's the thing this also includes a
special pot of long-term spending till
the end of the century on the Thames
Estuary which obviously covers London
and the South East Labour was talking
about spending to 2021 so what does this
chart look like if we just take that
period it looks a bit like this actually
look London the southeast on the areas
getting the most spending most spending
per head is going to Yorkshire and the
Humber which contains Doncaster and
Scheffer where much of this flooding is
actually happening then you've got the
southeast then the East Midlands and
London coming quite a long way down that
ranking but these regional breakdowns
only tell you so much in the bigger
picture is spending across England on
flood defences where it looked back in
2010 like it was going higher and higher
has actually weakened quite a lot a lot
weaker than many people expected
austerity did mean less spending than
many anticipated on flood defences but
contrary to what Labour has claimed when
you look at truly comparable numbers
it's not altogether obvious that
spending was dramatically skewed towards
London in the southeast